اذا خرج اول رائد فضاء من هذه المركبه
الفضائيه التي تقل رائدي الفضاء السعوديين
ريان والقرني وها هي صوره تبدو ان هناك
خروج لثاني
رواد الفضاء بعد خروج الاول
يتم الخروج وفقا لقواعد معينه من الناحيه
العلميه كما تشاهدون يخرج رائد الفضاء ثم
يقوم باصحابه ليقف في البدايه ثم بعد ذلك
يتم تحريكه الى الخارج هذه الرحله طبعا
تضم تقيمي او طاقم فضاء مكون من اربعه من
رواد الفضاء
اثنان سعوديان وهم ريان
والجرني بالاضافه الى رايضيه فضاء اخرين
اصطحبهما في هذه الرحله الى محطه الفضاء
الدوليه
اذا هذه هي اللحظه بالنسبه
للتجارب التي تجريها الدول هي لحظه
تاريخيه بالتاكيد كانت هناك متابعه كبيره
على مدى الايام العشر الماضيه لهذه الرحله
الفضائيه التي تاتي ضمن برنامج المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
لتطوير الابحاث الخاصه بها من الناحيه
العلميه هذه الرحله كانت تحظى في كل خطوه
من خطواتها باهتمام ومتابعه كبيره من كافه
الاوساط بالمناسبه هذا الاهتمام الذي كانت
تحظى به هذه الرحله لم يكن فقط في الاوساط
السعوديه او الاوساط العربيه ولكن كان
هناك اهتمام عالمي ايضا بهذه الخطوه التي
اقدمت عليها المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وفقا لرؤيه 20 30 اذا
يخرج الان رائد الفضاء الثالث في هذه الرح
بعد خروج اثنان منذ قليل تلاحظون العمليه
تتم بطريقه معينه سحب رائدي الفضاء للخارج
ثم ايقافهما
والتقدم بهم الى الامام وها هو تلويح الان
اعتقد ان هذا رائد الفضاء سيكون علي
بالتاكيد مع هذا التلويح باعتبار ان
خرج الان ثلاثه من رواد الفضاء وباقي في
هذه الرحله رائد كان هناك
رايي فضاء سعوديين ريان
والجرني بالاضافه الى فضاء اخرين خرج
ثلاثه والرابع الان سيخرج من هذه المركبه
الفضائيه التي عاشوا بها لمده عشره ايام
واجر بها العديد من التجارب وعاشوا فيها
الكثير من اللحظات كانت هناك حركه تفاعل
كبيره مع كل ما ينشره او تنشره ريان
والجرمي عن هذه الرحله والابحاث التي
يقومون بها والتجارب وفقا للمهامه
الفضائيه التي قامت بتحديدها هيئه الفضاء
السعوديه وفقا للبرنامج الفضائي الذي يتم
الاعتماد عليه اذا خرج الرائد الفضاء
الرابع
وبهذا يكون قد خرج الاربعه رواد اثنان
سعوديان واثنان اصطحبهما في هذه الرحله
هابطه بسلام وفقا للجدول الزمني وايضا
وفقا للمكان الذي كان مقرر له الهبوط على
متن هذه السفينه في المحيط الاطلسي وها هو
احتفالات من قبل الشركه التي تقوم بابحاث
الفضاء في شركه ناسا الامريكيه لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات